[음악]
제가 오랜만에
청담동에
드라이브스루를 또 하려고
영상을 좀 켰는데
드라이브스를 한지 거의 한 3년 정도
된 거 같아요 오랜만에 좀 날씨도
덥고 그리고
업데이트된 사항들도 좀 많아서
자동차로 이동하면서
청담동에 뭔가 좀 최근에
짓고 있는 건물이라든지 아니면 좀
이렇게 변화된
거리를 제가
[음악]
영상을 통해서 좀 소개해 드리도록
하겠습니다 저희 그때 영상으로 봤던
그 송원빌딩 여기 앞에 있는데이
건축비가 500억 들었죠
내부도 좀 상당히 잘 돼 있어서
만약에 청담동에 좀 오신 일이 있다면
소문 빌딩도 고쳐야 될 보시면 좋을
것 같고 그래서 일단 첫 번째로
학동사거리랑
청담사거리 그 다음에 압구정
로데오역에 있는 여기 이제 1번 구역
위주로 좀 볼게요
간이 전에 정우성 씨랑
이정재씨 건물을 살짝 보고 이동하도록
하겠습니다이 오른쪽에 코너에 보이는게
이제
정우성씨랑 이정재 씨가 같이
공동투자해서
매입한 건물입니다 그때 당시 아마
대지평당 한 2억 좀 안 되게
매입했는데
시세는 좀 많이 올랐죠
많이 오르긴 했는데
리모델링이 개인적으로 좀 아쉽긴
합니다
본격적으로 저기 1번 구역
똥사거리랑 청담사거리
압구정 로데오 이렇게
뛰고 있는 1번 구역 위주로
그쪽 지역이 청담동에서는 제일 좋아요
제일 좋은 지역이고
삼성가에서 그쪽에 빌딩도 좀 많이
샀고
[음악]
거기는 규모도 좀 크기 때문에
금액대가 좀 상당히 되게 높은
편입니다
[음악]
여러분들 여기 잘 아시죠 청담동
1번지
개발하고 있는데 이게 대지평당 한
4억 초중반 정도에 팔렸어요 그래서
매입한 다음에 지금 이제 신축
중인데이
업체가 그런 하이엔드 주거 개발을 좀
많이 하거든요 그래서 지금이 건물도
신축해서 아마 좀 커뮤니티 시설로 좀
만든다고 합니다
또 한번 유심히 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다
지금 저는
학동사거리에서 압구정 로데오 쪽으로
가고 있습니다
[음악]
바로 도장대로 이면이 제일 좋죠 여기
상권이 그래서 저쪽으로 가면 울프강도
있고
그 다음에 뭐
청담
스케줄 청담 유명한 맛집들이 좀 많이
밀집돼 있습니다
여기 우측에 보면 여기에 이제 그
임세령씨 건물이죠
이 위치가 굉장히 좋습니다 여기 지금
레스토랑 있는이 건물이
임세령시 건물이고
이쪽으로 쭉
올라가면요 앞에 이제 고센이 있죠
아마 이제 청담동 아시는 분들은 잘
아실텐데
우선이 이제 이쪽에 있고 저기 앞에
이제 스타벅스가 있는데
저게 아마 이제 정영진 부회장님
그리고 이쪽 대각선에 있는이 건물도
정용진 부회장님하고 저기
이마트24까지 아마 가지고 있을
겁니다 그리고요 앞에 이제 분더샵이
있는데 여기 일대로 이제까지 삼성
일가가 다 소유하고 있다
여기가 이제 명품거리죠 그래서 명품
거리가 한 2-3년 전만 해도 지금
상권이 많이 안 좋았다가
최근에는 좀 다시 사랑을 하는
얘깁니다
임차인들도 되게 좀 잘 들어와 있고
요즘에는
명품사로 좀 이렇게
백화점보다는 이렇게
단독 매장에 좀 많이 오시는 거
같아요
보시면 원래 여기가 다 복실이었는데
최근에 좀 다 맞춰졌어요
첫 번째 보신 구역의 뭐 이면에 있는
빌딩들은 뭐
웬만한 건 다 이제 1억 중반 이상
거의 뭐 2억이 쉽게 넘어가는 그런
곳이고
청담동에서 제일 금액대도 없고 제일
뭐 진짜 많이 하는 곳이 지금 일본
구역이라고 합니다
초기 앞에 이제 버버리라든지 되게
유명한
명품
업체들이 들어와 있고 그리고 이제 두
번째
구역으로 갈 건데 두 번째 구역은
여기 청담사거리에서 그 영동대구 남단
사거리 그 위쪽 부분입니다
한강 쪽 그래서 이쪽
구역 같은 경우에는 좀 1번
구역보다는 좀 주거가 좀 많이 밀집돼
있고 그리고 유명한 그런
하이엔드 주택들이 좀 이쪽에 많이
밀집돼 있습니다 대표적으로는
ph120담
그리고 막 상지타임 등등 되게 좀
유명한
고급주택이 많이 지금 밀집된 곳이라는
곳이었습니다
그리고 에테르노가 최근에 좀 잘
되면서
그 1번 구역이 있는 그 효성빌라
부지를 또 샀어요 그래서 거기 이제는
뭐 두 번째를 만든다고
작업 중인 걸로 알고 있습니다
그래서 거기도 좀 어떻게 개발할지
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
이제 2번 구역에 들어갈 건데
부산대로 바로 이면에이 넓은 도로가
제일 상권이 좋아요
[음악]
원래 이제 이쪽에 그
연예인 BC 건물이 있었죠 비 건물을
이제 또 매각을 했습니다
[음악]
우측에 보이는
가지고 있다 이제 매각을 했죠
[음악]
매각을 하고
강남역에 있는 건물을 샀습니다
이면 치고는 너무 좀 사이즈가 크긴
했습니다
여기 이면에 들어오면 다 이제 이런
고급스택이에요
[음악]
그래서 아까 1번 구역보다는
그렇게 뭔가 상권이 엄청 있거나 그런
곳은 아니에요
상권 있는 곳은 다 이제 그냥
도산대로 바로 이면에
[음악]
보조개 뭐 저쪽에 뭐 연예인분들도
이제 건물이 많아요 그래서 저쪽에
아까 들어오는 초입에 최진실 건물도
있고 여기 이제 FNC 사옥도 있고
그 다음 좌측에는
[음악]
이미연씨도 있습니다
죽어가 밀집돼 있고 그 다음에 여기
이제 좌측에 있는게
[음악]
언어 중간이죠
지금 이제
막 빵 타고 있습니다 그리고
좌측에 있는게 테르노죠 지금
다 올라갔어요 건물이 다 올라가서
지금
준공이고 올해 말 내년 초쯤 될 거
같아요
굉장히 좀 저도 이제 저게 건너편에서
한남동에서 봐도 눈에 되게 띄는 건물
같아요 제가 느끼기에는
이쪽 인근에서 좀 제일 선호하는 그런
고급 주택
[음악]
땅을
싸게 샀었어요 그때 당시에
딱 1억 초반 정도
800억 좀 안 되게 샀었는데
[음악]
엄청 많이
엄청
성공적인
분양이죠 여기 지금 보이시네 여기가
이제 ph16입니다
여기 뭐 고소영씨 살고 있고 일단
펜트하우스에
[음악]
동서 옆에 있는지가 저기 루시아
원래 이제 람보르기니 있었던
적당히 있었던 뭐 그 자리였는데 저게
펜트하우스가 한 300억 정도 돼요
지금 분양 중인데
그것도 한번 뭐 팔릴지 한번 좀
지켜봐야 될 것 같습니다
[음악]